Just by way of brief introduction, I
think the thing that makes my view
different on health is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician.
And in veterinary medicine, we don't
have health insurance for animals like
we do people. And if we were to use a
human health care type of system for
livestock, for instance, it'd be sticker
shock for you. Your hamburger would cost
you $275 a pound just to pay for the
health care. So, we learned a long time
ago in the animal industry that we could
keep the price of animal products such
as meat and dairy and poultry and eggs
down where the average American could
afford to eat them every day simply by
eliminating health care costs. That's I
think a very profound statement. Simply
by eliminating health care costs. We do
that in animals with simple little
nutritional formulas. That's why we have
mouse pellets and rat pellets and
hamster pellets and gerbil pellets and
guinea pig pellets and rabbit pellets
and canned and dry dog and cat food. And
we have sheep pellets and horse pellets
and calf pellets and dairy pellets and
monkey pellets and catfish pellets and
turkey pellets and duck pellets and
ostrich pellets and on and on and on.
You get the picture. Uh the reason why
we put all these various animal diets
into the pelletized form is so that
every mouthful is biochemically perfect.
Even the stupidest animal in the group
gets a perfect diet. They can't sort
through and just eat only the sunflower
seeds or the raisins. Their health and
production is not dependent on their
choices of food. We command them to eat
a certain way, and that's the way they
eat. And we get a uniform, a projected,
expected production. We've been so
successful doing this over the last 75
years that in the animal industry, we've
eliminated about 900 different diseases
that still plague human beings. We've
doubled and tripled their historical
lifespans in the last 60 years. Uh Uh 60
years ago, if you're old enough to
remember, an old dog used to be 10 years
old. Today, an old dog is 20 something.
Uh 10 years ago, an old cat was 12.
Today, an old cat is 25 or 30. And we
didn't do that with wonder drugs and
genetically engineered proteins or stem
cells or transplants. We did that simply
by adding vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals to their food. And that
kind of excited me. Uh, one more little
thing about my background. On a large
grant from the National Institutes of
Health during the 1960s,
I worked with Marlin Perkins from the
old Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom days. I
was one of his uh, veterinarians that
worked on this research project. Did
over 17,500
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings for a
comparison. And what I learned was,
ladies and gentlemen, was that every
animal and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease.
So, since 1964, I've been working very
hard to get the health industry to
appreciate this and not treat nutrition
as the stepchild of health, but actually
as the front piece of health. And it was
not very successful. So, I went back to
school Portland, Oregon, became a
actually a naturopathic physician, which
is kind of like an osteopath in Oregon.
Uh, we're primary care physicians. And
we
were able to begin in 1978 to use
everything I'd learned in veterinary
nutrition on my human patients. And I'm
here to tell you
that the concept of preventing and
curing diseases in animals with
nutritional formulas works just the same
in people. These are the sort of things
I would collect to um, share with my
patients. I I wanted to give my patients
a gift uh, sort of an incentive or bribe
to come to me as their doctor. And I
promised them I'd do everything I could
to get them to live to be 100 instead of
75. And this particular issue, September
2000 of uh, Scientific American was
almost totally devoted to 100-year-old
people and and what they did differently
and so forth. There were articles in
there by medical doctors and geneticists
and gerontologists and nutritionists.
And they were all coming from different
directions. So, there was a summary at
the end telling you what you were
supposed to learn by reading all this
different stuff. And basically they were
editorially scratching their head. They
couldn't figure out why the people who
lived to be 100 were the ones who were
rebellious and didn't listen to their
doctors' instructions. The people who
followed the doctors' instructions
didn't make it to 100. And they couldn't
figure out why. They wanted to do some
big research project to figure out why.
Well, you don't have to figure too long
because if the medical doctors' advice
isn't bringing you to 100, it's not good
advice. That's pretty simple. You don't
need a $50 study to figure that out.
Going back to April
of 1992, 12 years ago, almost 12 and 1/2
years ago, this was a cover article Time
magazine, very profound article.
Uh I think there were six positive pages
on nutrition uh in this issue. Again,
April, I think it was April 6th or April
7th, 1992, The Real Power of Vitamins,
and they meant, as most people do when
they say vitamins, they mean vitamins
and minerals. You know, nobody says,
"Honey, did you take your vitamin B1,
B2, B3, B5, B6? Did you take your folic
acid? Did you buy your choline, your
B12? Did you take your calcium,
magnesium, manganese? Did you take your
phenylalanine and your arginine and your
cysteine and your methionine amino
acids? Did you take your omega-3s?"
People say, "Honey, did you take your
vitamins this morning?" And it's kind of
this generic shorthand for did you take
your supplements? And they use it the
same way here cuz it kind of fit the
layout. Uh The Real Power of Vitamins
and Minerals, etc., etc. New research
shows it may help fight cancer, heart
disease, and the ravages of aging. Well,
back um when I started seeing human
patients back in 1978 as a physician, I
wanted to have some kind of animal
model, being a veterinarian, and and a
human model to give them so they didn't
think it was some outrageous thing that
I was coming up with, some pipe dream.
And looking around, sure enough, I found
a guy by the name of Clive McCay, and he
did his research back in the 1920s. And
uh geneticists like to claim him, but he
was just a physiologist. He published
his landmark papers 1935.
And basically what he did was take three
groups of rats and and gave them the
same basic rat pellet of the day from
the 1920s, which is quite a remarkable
step because research rats before this
rat pellet would only live maybe six to
a 10 months after weaning when they just
feed them rolled oats and carrots and
things like that. But once they came out
with the nutritional pellet of the day,
they lived me an average of 2 years.
That was just remarkable for research.
Well, he was the only guy at that time
who was tinkering around with
macronutrients, proteins, fats, and
carbohydrates to see what you could do
to make the animals live longer. And in
group number two,
he gave them the same basic pellet as
group number one, but he cut the
carbohydrate calories by 30%, kept the
vitamins minerals the same, and they
lived
50% longer than group number one. Got
kind of excited about that. So, group
number three,
he cut the carbohydrates by 60% from
group number one, kept the vitamins
minerals the same, and they lived twice
as long.
And they thought they had the answer.
Well, it wasn't quite that simple. Uh
when they redid the studies in pigs and
dogs and monkeys and spiders and all
kinds of bugs and birds and things, they
found out that the secret was that he
kept the vitamins minerals the same.
And the the secret to this longevity by
tinkering with the food is that you want
to have a high level of vitamins and
minerals per carbohydrate calorie.
That's one of the reasons why low-carb
diets are good for you, why they work to
help you lose weight, but also live
longer. Even though people aren't
supplementing, they have a modest amount
of vitamins and minerals in their diet.
And if they cut the carbohydrates, that
means your concentration of vitamins and
minerals per carbohydrate calorie is
going up.
And that's the thing you have to look
for. Well, I had a very exciting animal
model that went back to 1935. Then I
wanted a human model,
and I ran into a guy by the name of Art
Linkletter. How many of you remember Art
Linkletter?
Yeah, if you're over 40 years old, you
remember Art Linkletter. He was a great
TV and radio uh host, and he invented
the Kids Say the Darndest Things
concepts, and he was very funny without
saying four-letter words, so I always
appreciated him. And he was kind of
interesting and I ran into him when I
was looking for a human model for
100-year-olds and he wanted to live to
be 100. And there was all kinds of
newspaper interviews I ran into. Uh he
wanted to be 100 and he had gotten kind
of excited about this possibility by
reading a uh 1933
Pulitzer Prize-winning novel by James
Hilton called Lost Horizon. Okay, well,
Lost Horizon, if you if you don't
remember the book, it coined a term
James Hilton coined a term called
Shangri-La. How many of you have heard
of Shangri-La? I think most people have
heard of that. And um this was this
mythical place, kind of like a place
where you could live in this
microenvironment that was perfect,
almost like Eden, and you could eat
everything there and you lived a
spiritual life and you could live be
200, 300 years of age. And it was based
on some people in what is now Eastern
Pakistan in a single valley called
Hunza.
Art Linkletter hired an eye doctor by
the name of Alan Bannick to go to Hunza
and find out what their secret was cuz
at the time in the 1930s, they were the
healthiest and the longest-lived people
on Earth. Now, the most remarkable thing
about the Hunzas is they were a third
world country. They had no electricity,
no indoor plumbing, no telephones. They
had no hospitals, no doctors, no
pharmacies, no pharmaceuticals, no
prescriptions. I mean, they had nothing.
And yet, they were the longest-lived and
healthiest people on Earth.
And so, uh Art Linkletter wanted to find
out what their secret was. So, Alan
Bannick goes there and he really
couldn't quite pick it out. He was an
eye doctor, didn't know a lot about
everything. So, he was very good about
writing about what he observed, but he
didn't pinpoint any particular thing. He
just says, "Well, here it all is. Pick
what you want."
But, there are two things that were
valuable knowing what we know about
Clive McCay's animal models. Number one,
these people live in a single valley at
19,500
ft elevation. If you've ever farmed, you
know that when you're above the
timberline like that, I mean, kind of
like double. The timberline is like
7,000 ft. So, we're at almost three
times the height of the timberline and
nothing grows there. Very hostile
environment. They couldn't grow rice,
they couldn't grow potatoes, uh they
couldn't grow corn, but they could grow
wheat. But, because of the very short
and very hostile growing season, their
yield was very, very small and their sum
total of their carbohydrate intake each
day was one little chapati bread, looked
like a tortilla, a flour tortilla, a
very small one,
one a day per person. That was their sum
total of their carbohydrate intake. The
rest of their food was lamb and mutton,
goat, cheese and milk. Uh they cooked in
butter.
That was it. Had few vegetables, you
know, like tomatoes and carrots and
cabbage.
And so, they had a very low carbohydrate
diet. So, that kind of fit Clive McCay's
thing, 60% less carbohydrate than the
control rats.
Well, where did they get their extra
minerals, their extra vitamins? Well, so
happens Alan Bannick pointed out
something that I used to do as a kid in
these people. This is a a cultural thing
that they did that occurs thousands of
years ago in Asians and Europeans and
Africans. This I don't I don't know who
came up with it first, but it's been
used since the beginning of time, since
the dawn of written history. And uh it's
something many of you've done. How many
of you ever taken wood ashes from a
fireplace or a cooking stove and put in
your garden? How many of you ever done
that?
Okay. Well, he noted that every morning
they did that. They took the wood ashes
from their fireplaces and their heating
fires, and they put these wood ashes in
their gardens every morning.
Well, the wood ashes are the minerals
that are left when you burn away the
carbon in the wood.
So, every morning they were putting
minerals back into their gardens.
Now, that that is a very profound thing.
It sounds so simple. Now, we and as
Americans used to do that because we all
came from a background of Europeans or
Asians or Africans. And so, everybody
came to the United States in the 1700s,
1800s, 1900s with this history, but
something changed in our culture in
1940.
This was the end of healthy Americans in
1940. Actually started before that.
Actually started the Industrial
Revolution, but it was just a trickle.
But, they they shut the spigot off for
uh intake of minerals in 1940. What
happened in 1940? Everybody got a modern
kitchen. Electricity, gas, propane. Are
there any wood ashes left when you cook
with an electric stove? Are there any
wood ashes left when you cook with
natural gas? Are there any wood ashes
left when you cook with propane or
microwave? No. And so, as soon as we got
the modern kitchen,
there was no more wood ashes to put into
the gardens. And so, our source of
minerals dried up just like flipping off
a switch. And so, we're not eating the
same as we did, just even culturally. Uh
we're not eating the same. Just assuming
that all our vegetables uh are as
healthy as they were 100 years ago,
we're not putting the minerals back in
because we don't have the wood ashes
from our cooking fires and our heating
fires to put back in the land. Well,
human beings need 90 essential
nutrients, 60 minerals, 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, three essential
fatty acids to flourish and reproduce
and do well and repel diseases and so
forth.
And plants only need nine. Plants are
very simple organisms. I have a degree
in agriculture and I can tell you
factually that plants only require nine
to be uh in a in a state of flourishing
and robust health. But they can get away
with three. Give the farmer the maximum
yields in terms of tons and bushels per
acre. That's why you see bags of
fertilizer with NPK, nitrogen,
phosphorus, potassium, 10-10-10,
10-16-12, cuz different plants require
different ratios of those three
elements.
One's an element, the other two are
minerals.
And we need 60. Where are we going to
get the other 57?
Well, first of all, our food plants
cannot give you everything you need just
by eating well. Plants are very good
about making vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids. When they're well
nourished, they have to have at least
those three nutrients, NPK, to make
vitamins, amino acids, and fatty acids.
These are carbon compounds, and plants
can take carbon dioxide out of the air
and use the sun's energy in a process
known as photosynthesis to manufacture
long carbon chains and many of these are
actually configured into vitamins, amino
acids, and fatty acids. And plants can
do that. They can make it. And if you
spend 8 hours a day shopping and picking
out everything at the perfect stage of
ripeness and you cook food properly and
you store food properly,
you might, only with the grace of God,
get enough vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids.
But, it's worse than Vegas when it comes
to the minerals. Plants cannot
manufacture minerals. If you can find me
any plant that'll manufacture any
mineral, I don't care if it's lead, I'll
give you a million dollars in small
bills, tax-free,
uh and any offshore account you want.
You'll be a bazillionaire soon.
But, there are no such plants. Plants
don't make minerals. They can't make
minerals. They're not genetically
capable of making minerals. They get
their minerals from the soil. And
unfortunately, nutritional minerals do
not occur in a uniform blanket around
the crust of the earth. Nutritional
minerals occur in veins like chocolate
and chocolate ripple ice cream.
Nutritional minerals occur in veins like
gold and silver. And the odds of you and
I getting all 60 essential minerals just
by eating well is zero. I don't care if
you spend a million dollars a day for
food and you live on the very finest
caviar and Australian wine and artichoke
hearts imported from Costa Rica and all
this wonderful food, guess what? You're
still going to be deficient in minerals.
As I told you,
I did all this research and found out
that every animal and every human being
who died of natural causes died of
nutritional deficiency disease. And as
you might expect spending the
multi-millions of dollars, actually 7
and 1/2 million dollars to do this
research, wrote several papers, wrote 75
scientific papers, were published in
medical journals, veterinary journals,
wrote textbooks, big thousand-page jobs,
and lectured to doctors many times at
their continuing education meetings. And
I was not successful in getting people
who were in a position of authority,
either in medical research or the
government, to get excited about
preventing and curing diseases in people
with nutrition like we did in animals.
And I knew this is an important concept
back in the '60s and that's why I went
back to school, became a physician.
Well, this came out just about 40 years
later. This is a World Health
Organization study. Nutrition key factor
in mortality. Study finds life
expectancy closely mirrors dietary
factors.
Well, look at there. Okay?
And the most important sentence they had
in the whole article was it says
inadequate intake of three key
micronutrients, zinc, iron, and vitamin
A is responsible for an unexpectedly
high burden of of disease. Well, there's
90 essential nutrients. They they didn't
talk about the other 87. They just
talked about three. Vitamins could help
2 billion kids. This just came out March
of 2004, a couple months ago.
Vitamins could help 2 billion kids. How
many people are there on Earth? 6
billion. That's a third of the
population. Any doctor anybody who says
that, you know, there's no evidence
to support a claim that you can prevent
and cure diseases with vitamins and
minerals is a fool.
Um how many of you've ever heard of
scurvy? Raise your hand. You know you
can prevent and cure scurvy with vitamin
C. How many of you've ever heard of
rickets? You can prevent and cure
rickets with vitamin D. What about
anemia? You know you can prevent and
cure anemia with iron and copper and
folic acid and B12 and many other
nutrients. What about goiter? You know
you can prevent and cure goiter with
iodine and copper and selenium and and
tyrosine, an amino acid. Uh what about
things like oh osteoporosis? You can
actually prevent and cure that with with
calcium and magnesium and sulfur and
many other uh nutrients. And what about
uh diseases like night blindness? You
can prevent and cure night blindness
with vitamin A. And then there's
beri-beri with congestive heart failure.
You can prevent and cure that with
thiamine or vitamin B1. And and then
there's a pellagra with the
schizophrenia and all the dermatitis and
diarrhea that goes along with that. You
can prevent and cure that with niacin or
vitamin B3. And I could go through all
the 90 essential nutrients
because they're called essential
nutrients for two reasons. Number one,
our bodies cannot manufacture them and
we must consume them every day either as
food or as supplements.
And number two, if any of them are
missing, you get some horrible
collection of degenerative diseases,
many of which are life-threatening. And
so anybody who says there's no evidence
to support a claim that you can prevent
and cure disease with vitamins and
minerals is a fool. And the last place
you want a fool in your life is your
doctor.
You have a doctor who believes that, I'd
get up and leave. I would not go back to
them because you don't want anybody that
ignorant in charge of your health. Cuz
well, my doctor says I can just eat well
and get everything I need.
That was never true, but
you know, why do people in
Ethiopia live to be an average of 29, we
live to be an average of 70 something?
Is it genetic? No. It's because they
don't have a lot of minerals in their
soil. Sand. Let's just look at this is
actually a study from just came out this
month. It's the June-July
2004 issue of Mother Earth and it was
actually what they did was take a USDA,
United States Department of Agriculture
study where they compared the 1975 to
2004 values in food. And when you look
at just wheat for instance, the calcium
content in wheat went down 22% during
that time period. When you look at let's
look at another mineral, potassium went
down 6%. Phosphorus went down 24%. Then
you look at calcium in apples, went down
14%. In blueberries, it went down 60%.
In onions, it went down 18%. In green
beans, it went down 33%. In broccoli,
went down 54%.
Wait a minute, you're supposed to eat
broccoli. Eat three servings of broccoli
a day. Eat 5 lbs of broccoli a day, you
get all the calcium you need.
So it went down 54%. That means you need
to eat 7 and 1/2 lbs of broccoli a day
to get your calcium. Yeah, man, that's
exciting. Eat 7 and 1/2 lbs of broccoli.
I mean, you're going to generate enough
gas to run a turbine, you know.
You look at iron here. Let's look at
iron in apples, it went down 60% in that
same time period. In blueberries, it
went down 72%. In onions, it went down
62%.
Uh let's see here. Oh, in carrots, it
went down 57%.
And broccoli, it went down 33%. Let's
look at vitamin A. Now, the vitamin A is
interesting because it's a carbon
compound that plants can make if they
have all the nutrition they need. They
have to still they have to have mineral
cofactors to be able to make the carbon
compounds, right?
So let's look at vitamin A. Apples went
down 40% in that time period.
Blueberries went down 40%. Onions went
down 95%. Tomatoes went down 31%. Corn
went down 400%.
Well, I'm eating plenty of corn, so I'm
I'm getting all the beta-carotene I
need. Went down 400%.
I'm eating cornbread. I'm getting all
the beta-carotene I need.
Broccoli went down 74%. Vitamin C,
legendary, made by plants. Blueberries
went down 31%. Onions went down 36%.
Spinach went down 45%.
They actually checked 12 different
nutrients. They just get a little
summary here. One of the thing I think
was important in this article. In 1992,
the USDA, the United States Department
of Agriculture, came out and said, "If
everybody just took the minimum daily
requirement of all the known essential
nutrients,
they're going to reduce the actual
reporting level of cancer by 28%. You
can reduce cardiovascular disease in
America by 25%, reduce arthritis by 50%,
reduce respiratory and infectious
disease by 20%, and reduce infant and
maternal deaths by 50%. If you just If
everybody Everybody just took the
vitamins and minerals. But doctors today
still say Medical doctors still today
say, "You can get everything you need by
eating your basic four food groups. Just
eat variety. Have three different colors
on your plate, and and you'll do fine."
Well, doctors should be put in jail for
25 years to life
because it's reckless endangerment.
Through their ignorant pontifications,
they have killed more people in all the
wars in the world put together.
It's going to get worse.
It's going to get worse. This just came
out
June 16th,
2004. UN warns 1/3 of the earth is at
risk of becoming a desert.
Can you grow good food in the desert? I
don't think so.
This is a creeping catastrophe.
And we're talking about in the United
States, we're talking about losing at
least 1/3 of the land that we can grow
food on now. There's just no nutrition
left in the soil.
And so, how do we protect people?
Uh, you just eat better?
Eat more broccoli?
Well, that's not it. That's That's not
going to work, folks.
The only way you can make sure you're
getting all these nutrients is to
consciously put them in your mouth. You
have to supplement. Well, despite kind
of a tragic outlook here,
there are people who do make it to 100.
Percentage-wise, it's very small in the
United States. We're the third largest
population in the world, but there are
people who live long, healthy lives. And
again, they tend to be rebellious
patients who don't listen to their
doctors. They do things that doctors
don't want them to do.
And they're the ones who make it to 100.
The ones who follow their doctors'
instructions exactly don't make it.
How many of you had somebody in your
family who lived to be 80, 90 years of
age?
I think most Americans have had
somebody, unless they're all horse
thieves got hung early, but, you know,
most people have somebody 80, 90 in
their family.
You can remember back. They ate ate eggs
every morning. They ate salt their food.
They ate red meat. They ate their
chicken skin. Uh, they used butter. They
didn't even have margarine back in those
days. And the only exercise they did
when they came home from a hard day's
work was to fall asleep on the floor in
their bib overalls. They didn't even
have a Lazy Boy chair to sleep in.
So, let's see some of these rebellious
people.
Ralph Charles from Somerset, Ohio, which
is in the middle of the state of Ohio,
back in, uh, October 1999, turned 100.
And the fascinating thing to me about
Ralph Charles was that he was still, at
his birthday at 100, was still piloting
commercial charter flights carrying
paying passengers around the central
part of the United States.
To me, he doesn't look like what you
expect a decrepit 100-year-old to look
like. To me, he looks like he's in his
maybe late 70s, early 80s.
Had no restrictions on his pilot's
license or health papers at 100.
And then this gal here,
Connie Douglas Reeves, 4 days after this
article came out, September 26, 2002,
she turned 101 and she was entered into
the Cowgirl Hall of Fame cuz she'd
taught 30,000 young women how to ride
western saddles and and barrel race.
And to me, she doesn't look like a
shrinking violet. She doesn't look like
somebody who would say, "Well, whatever
you say, doctor. I mean, after all,
you're the one with the white coat and
the stethoscope around your neck, so I'm
here for your advice. If that's what you
say, I'll do it.
You know, she's got her shoulders back,
her chin's out, and she's just saying,
you know, "Knock that chip off." I mean,
anybody who deals with horses for 101
years that she's been rolled on, kicked,
thrown, bit, stomped, and she's standing
straight and tall, and you can just
imagine a doctor saying to her, "Connie,
you're 101 years old now. I want you to
give up salt. We got to worry about your
blood pressure." She says, "Well, up
yours, doc. I've been using salt since
before you were born. I'm not going to
quit now." You got to give up eggs. We
got to worry about your cholesterol. She
goes,
"Okay, I've been eating eggs forever,
and I'm not going to give them up."
Well, she's a little rough for you. You
might appreciate Harold Stilson from
Deerfield Beach, Florida. In May of
2001, he turned 101 and went out and
played golf for his birthday, and he hit
a six-hole-in-one at 101.
Now, you have to have good vision to be
able to see that little stick 108 yards
away. You have to have a good grip on
that club, and you have to have good
eye-hand coordination to hit that ball,
right?
Tiger Woods can't even hit a hole-in-one
anymore.
I mean, he's he's done since he let them
do that arthroscopic surgery on his knee
and get that radio cartilage. I mean, he
hasn't won a match since he had those
two surgeries.
He should sue his doctors
whoever talked him into that. I was just
in Puerto Rico with my dear wife in a
training thing, and this gal here, her
name was Ramona Trinidad Iglesias
Jordan, and she turned 100 She actually
died at 114. She was the oldest living
I guess you call her an American, you
know, American territory kind of thing,
114.
And she looks pretty good for 114. She
looks like she's 80 years old.
And she lived up in the mountains in the
in the rainforest of Puerto Rico. Never
been to a doctor. They're kind of
bragging about that in the newspaper.
It doesn't seem to matter what you eat,
as long as you keep the minerals up and
the carbohydrate calories down.
This gal here, Dora Ramathiebi from
South Africa,
was born in June of 1881.
Uh and I don't know how long she lived
cuz this is a birthday announcement.
Didn't keep track of her. Uh turned 114
in 1995. When she was asked, "Dora, what
do you attribute your health and your
longevity to?" She didn't say I was born
in Scripps Hospital.
She was born in a straw hut caulked with
cow dung.
Her mama peed in the dust to make mud to
smear all over that child to keep the
flies from eating her. How do I know
that? Cuz I lived in South Africa for 2
years and attended many births, even as
a veterinarian, cuz I was the only
medical person around. And guess what?
That's what they do.
Uh, she didn't say I kept my cholesterol
down and gave up salt and went to my
annual physical.
You think she did all that living out in
the bush in Africa 114 years ago? No.
Uh, she ate locusts, you know,
grasshoppers, not the tree, pumpkin
seeds, tortoise meat, wild herbs, dried
fruit, and a cup of coffee. Did she say
rice, bread, potatoes, corn? No.
She had a very low carbohydrate diet.
The only carbohydrate she took in was a
little bit of dried fruit, and they
don't get much of that out in the middle
of the bush of Africa.
It's kind of a special thing people give
to each other there.
Had a very low carbohydrate diet, had
some essential fatty acids from the from
the pumpkin seeds, and she got some
protein from the grasshoppers and the
tortoise meat. She may have gotten some
vitamin C and folic acid and
beta-carotene from the herbs if she ate
them raw when they picked them for maybe
green vegetables. Well, guess what they
do in Africa.
I kind of gave you a hint earlier on.
Every morning they take the wood ashes
from their heating and cooking fires,
and they put them in their gardens where
they grow their squash and cucumbers and
carrots and tomatoes and cabbage. So,
recycling minerals, low carbohydrate
diet. Did she have access to
vaccinations and penicillin and all that
stuff and great doctors from Harvard
Medical School and Mayo Clinic? No.
Living out in the bush, couldn't read,
couldn't even get an Advil.
One of my favorite birth announcements
is a French lady
uh, by the name of Jeanne Calment, um,
in February of 1995, she was documented
by the Guinness World Book of Records
being the oldest living woman at that
time. There were hundreds of women who
claimed to be older than she was, but
she was the only one that had the
paperwork to prove, to the satisfaction
of the Guinness World Book of Records,
that February 21st, 1995, she was in
fact 120.
February 21st, 1996, she turned 120
one. February 21st, 1997, she turned
122, and she died in August of 19
uh '97 at age 122 years and 164 days.
She was 122 and 1/2 when she died. She
died suddenly of a stroke. She was up
singing "Frère Jacques" for God's sake.
"Frère Jacques, Frère Jacques." Cooking
her eggs.
Fell over dead. That was it.
No nursing home. I mean, nothing.
No cancer, no heart disease,
uh no Alzheimer's disease. She was
bright and mentally alert until the day
she died. No diabetes. This came out in
October when I was in Adelaide,
Australia. It was Adelaide, Australia
newspaper. They have a lot of stuff from
Southeast Asia, as you can imagine. Uh
this guy here,
um a tiger hunter, a Cambodian tiger
hunter, said to be the world's oldest
man has died at age 122. Sek Yi, who was
also martial arts expert, attributed his
longevity and that of his wife, Long Uk,
108, to smoking and prayer. Well, I can
go for the prayer part, Pastor Joe,
but I want to know what he was smoking
and if he inhaled.
There's also a Sydney, Australia
newspaper, also in 2003. A Brazilian
believed to be the world's oldest woman
has died at age 124. Maria Etelvina de
Santos died of a stroke in Salvador. Her
birth certificate said she was a
descendant of African slaves, born in
June of 1878.
Was she born in Scripps Hospital? Did
she have vaccinations and penicillin?
Uh no, she was born in a straw hut caked
with mud, and since her parents came
from Africa,
her mama peed in the dust to make mud to
smear all over that child to keep the
flies and mosquitoes from eating her.
Turned out to be the old How many people
in San Diego have lived to be 124?
Here's a gal who made it 120. I don't
know if she's still alive, maybe.
She's a gal by the name of Elizabeth
Israel.
And um this was back in January of 2001.
She was born in 1875.
She was born in the Caribbean on the
island of Dominica according to her
birth and baptismal records. Well, how
do these old people have so many birth
records? That's because the Spanish set
all that stuff up in 1541.
They set up a birth certificate system.
Anybody who was involved in the Spanish
churches got a birth certificate. Uh
here in the United States they say,
"Well, yeah, so-and-so claims to be 130
years old, but they don't have a birth
certificate." That's cuz they were born
in, you know, 1905 and they still
weren't still weren't issuing birth
certificates in Bean Bag, Iowa, right?
Okay, one last one. I think you'll get
the message here and then we'll move on
to the meat of this thing. This gal
here,
uh Mazumi Dusti from Iran, uh back in
January 1995 and this uh her obituary is
published in the Rocky Mountain News out
of um Denver, Colorado, said that she
died at age 161. That seems pretty
outrageous, but you have to actually
give some credibility to this obituary
because she was survived by six living
children ranging in age from 120 to 128
and none of them had left home to go to
college yet.
They were still babies.
Her oldest son said his mother had never
visited a doctor. She never took any
prescription medications. She only used
herbs during her life.
There's messages all over these birth
announcements and obituaries, ladies and
gentlemen.
None of them are just swooning over
their cholesterol-lowering statin drugs.
None of them are swooning over eating
Egg Beaters.
These are all primitive people.
There's clues here. But what do
primitive people do every morning?
They take the wood ashes from their
cooking and heating fires and they put
them in their gardens.
We have electric stoves. And so how do
you
replace what we gave up for the
convenience of a modern kitchen? You
have to consciously supplement and put
them in your mouth.
If you don't do that, you're doomed to
suffer all the terrible diseases you can
suffer from.
Now, geneticists tell us we can live to
be well beyond 100. We have the
genetics. I don't care if everybody in
your family died at 35. Everybody in
this room has the genetics to live well
beyond 100. The short version of why we
don't is because we do too many bad
things and not enough of the good
things. I mean, that's the shortest way
I can say it.
It's always amazing to me why people go
to medical doctors for advice on health
and longevity. I have to ask my doctor.
I just hear that so many times, I want
to choke people. In my tape Dead Doctors
Don't Lie, I said the average medical
doctor lives to be 58, and medical
doctors, I mean, they just got so
hysterically angry with me, you can't
believe how angry they got with me with
that. I mean, they called me every kind
of name you could call another human
being.
And reported me to every agency they
could think of, and some they made up,
and they they didn't want to believe me,
which I did a survey. I took all these
obituaries in medical journals and add
them up the ages and divide by the
number of doctors, got a simple average,
and said doctors live to be 57.6. I
rounded up to 58, gave them the benefit
of the doubt. And they did their own
study. Came out 3 years later, 1999,
said Wallach was wrong.
The average doctor doesn't live to be
58, they live to be 56. Wallach was a
liar.
And so why do we go to medical doctors
for advice on health and longevity? When
they only live to be 56. I mean, it's
outrageous. I mean, you wouldn't do that
in any other industry. Why would you go
to Mr. Goodwrench to have your car
maintained if if the word got out that
his cars that he maintained only went
5,000 miles?
Or they burned up. The reason is
twofold. I pondered on this a long time.
They have convinced everybody they're
the go-to people.
I mean, you can't even put on a Band-Aid
without asking your doctor.
I mean, where are the medical doctors? I
mean, we have to get everybody to fight
for insurance, right? Because
there's 30 million people in America
without health insurance. I mean, the
country's doomed without health
insurance.
Secondly,
they've been able to relegate all other
health
practices, even 10,000 year-old ones
like Ayurvedic medicine from India and
and traditional Chinese medicine,
they've been able to relegate them to
quackery.
They've been able to convince the
government that they're the go-to
people.
Chiropractors and
acupuncturists, Ayurvedic medical
practitioners, these guys are all
quacks.
Insurance can't pay quacks.
If a patient goes to them, we got to put
them in jail for practicing medicine
without a license.
They've politically and financially
been able to kill their competition.
Now, the Sherman Antitrust Act was
actually um
put into law in 1895.
Any industry that does that gets knocked
down. My Bell tried it and they broke
them up. Why doesn't the government
break up the medical profession? I'm
going to show you why in a second. It's
pretty scary. Well, if we're getting our
our money's worth, you might be able to
say, "Well, they're crooks and
scoundrels and all that kind of stuff,
but but because we're getting our
money's worth, it might be okay."
Let's see if we're getting our money's
worth. First of all, each year the
entire world spends 2.7 trillion, that's
with a T, 2.7 trillion dollars for
health care.
That's a gob of money, 2.7 trillion
dollars for health care. Now, that 2.7
trillion dollars, the United States
alone each year spends 1.6 trillion,
more than half.
So, we better rank pretty high since
we're spending more than half. We're
spending more money for health care than
all the other nations in the world put
together.
So, let's just see where we rank. In
April of 1990,
I found the first public printing of
where we ranked. This was a World Health
Organization and the Center for Disease
Control uh out of Atlanta, Georgia, came
together and they came up with this
survey. They said, "Out of the top 32
industrialized nations, the United
States ranked 17th." In April of 1990,
there were 16 other countries whose
peoples were healthier than we were and
lived longer than we did.
And yet we spend more money for health
care than all of them put together.
The entire world, and we rank 17th.
Japanese ranked number one at 79.1. You
say, "Well, that was a bad study. Let's
redo it." Well, they did 10 years later,
June 2000, they redid it. Japan
maintained number one, but they dropped
from 79.1 down to 74.5. So, this is our
chance to catch up and surpass them, at
least gain on them, right?
Instead, we dropped from 17th longevity
all the way down to 24th. Now, there's
23 other countries whose people is live
longer than we are and healthier than we
are and yet we spend more money for
health care than all the other countries
in the world.
That give you some sense that we're
going in the right direction? Well,
doesn't me.
I'm just a dumb farm boy from Missouri,
but the numbers don't equate to being on
the right track.
That's give you the sense that doctors
are laying awake day and night trying to
figure out how to cure us of all these
terrible diseases? Doesn't me. What
about all these 250,000 pharmaceuticals
and prescription drugs they have in the
PDR, Physician's Desk Reference? If you
take out the 500 antibiotics out of
there out of the 250,000 drugs, which
are designed to cure infections, you
know, like strep throat and scarlet
fever and
pneumonia and things like that,
there's 249,500
pharmaceuticals left and you can't find
one of them that are designed to cure
anything. They're all designed to milk
the insurance system.
There's no laws requiring pharmaceutical
companies to make cures and so they
don't.
There's no laws requiring medical
doctors to cure people when there's
cures available, so they don't.
Now, that's a mind blower.
There's no law requiring doctors to cure
people when there's cures available, so
they don't.
Now, we would all like to think in our
heart of hearts
that doctors, medical doctors, are
altruistic and they're in the business
of helping people. Well, if you believe
that, you're living in la-la land.
Their primary concern is not to help
people.
Their primary concern is to crack that
financial nut every month.
Health spending has hit the biggest
surge in 11 years. Must be Bush's fault.
God, it's Bush's fault.
No.
That started out 20 years ago when we
came up with the um managed care. How
many heard of managed care?
Now, managed care was designed to stop
excessive tests and the unnecessary
surgical procedures and unnecessary
prescriptions by doctors and it was
working.
But doctors' incomes got cut in half. I
mean, their lifestyles were going in the
tank. So, they started whispering to
their patients, "Look, there's some
beady-eyed accountant kept you from
getting that test. Now, I'm the doctor.
I know you needed that test and he won't
let me do it. You got to pay for it out
of your own pocket.
We can't have that.
And so by continuing to whisper in the
patient's ears after 10 or 11 years,
patients finally kind of rose up and
Medicare had to back out of the managed
care system.
And the day after the day after Medicare
backed out of the controlled environment
where the bean counter was in charge of
what you got instead of the doctor,
went up 17%. Healthcare went up 17%.
It's been going up almost 50% every
quarter now since then because they're
totally unchecked.
It's political suicide for anybody to
just try and stem the tide.
Right now we're spending $1.6 trillion a
year for healthcare. And I'm going to
show you what to do about it. Age 65
workforce. Wait a minute, workforce age
60 you're supposed to retire at 65. What
is this workforce thing?
According to the US Department of Labor,
95% of all Americans who retire at 65
retire below the poverty level. $2,000 a
month is a poverty cutoff.
95% of Americans after working 40 years
in America retire below poverty level
and have to do something else. You got
to go back to work.
Because at 1,200 bucks a month doesn't
cut it. You got to sell your house you
paid on for 30 years to move into a
scroungy little apartment
because you can't afford the taxes every
year. Can't afford the utilities, the
upkeep.
What a What a crummy deal. Well, whose
fault is it? What's the most common
thread that people complain about when
they retire?
Healthcare.
Oh, I They testify before Congress. I I
couldn't eat lunch today cuz I I had to
pay for my drugs. I
I I can't eat. I have to pay for my
drugs. Why do you have to pay for your
drugs? Cuz my doctor told me. And then
this is the most outrageous thing I've
ever seen. Last year, 9 months ago,
whatever it is, you may all remember
this, Vons and Ralphs and Kroger's,
70,000
workers from from grocery stores went on
strike in Southern California alone and
they were striking all over the country
in sympathy with them because over a
3-year period between 2000 and 2003, the
healthcare cost for their insurance went
up 50% went up from $6,000 a year to
$9,000 a year. And the contract said
that the the store chains were going to
pay for their health care. And so these
people struck
the stores, I don't know, 3 months, 4
months, whatever it was.
A lot of them closed their doors and
went out of business.
When they did come back, all the
customers had started going to Costco's.
A lot cheaper. And so a lot of them are
still not open 24 hours like they used
to be cuz they don't have any business
anymore.
That strike killed the jobs for these
70,000 people.
They were striking the wrong person. Why
would they strike the company that's
paying their mortgage and paying the
food for their kids
and paying for their car payment? They
should have been striking the doctors.
They should have been striking the
insurance companies. They should have
been striking the hospitals and clinics.
I mean, the doctors are really smart.
They're sitting there playing cards in
the in their country club.
Well, they go, we got this army, all
these union guys out there striking
them. Somebody's going to pay us. We'll
get the government to do it. The company
We don't care if they all go bankrupt
and lose their job. They're going to pay
us.
So, I'm getting close
to telling you what I what we do to
solve this problem. I I gave you kind of
a hint there.
What do you do with a failed and corrupt
system? Do you keep feeding it more
money?
Oh, well, the mafia, we got to pay them
more money. They'll be good to us if we
just pay them more money.
Outsourcing the American dream. Have we
lost a few jobs in Southern California?
Whoa.
They're going to India faster than you
can name them. Telephone operators in
the United States average $12.50 an hour
plus health benefits.
In India, they make less than a dollar
an hour and no health benefits. Payroll
clerks in Asia will make less than $2 an
hour, no health benefits. Their
counterparts in the US make $15.17 an
hour plus health benefits.
And so when the health care goes up and
the union demands more money to pay the
health care, guess what the company
says?
Adios, amigo.
Close the door and they're off to India.
You can't blame those companies. I mean,
they're working on 1% margins of profit.
They got to worry about their
stockholders.
And so, if you push too much, it's like
the old pinball machine. Some of you
older remember the old pinball machines
before computers? You had 1,800 points
left before you could win a free game,
and you started pushing that thing too
hard to keep that ball up there, what
happened?
Tilt. Game over. You I hated to see
that. Game over. Game over. Game over.
That's what happens when you push the
employers too much now.
They have other options. They can just
close their doors and go to India.
You know, with today's electronics,
three rings.
And they say, "Howdy, how can I help
you?" And you think you've called Texas.
You just hit New Delhi. To kind of tell
you where, you know, spiritually medical
doctors come from.
But they're not going to treat lawyers
and their families who sue them for
malpractice. And so, when that came out,
I sent out a news release. Nobody picked
it up. I didn't think they would, but I
felt better. I sent out a news release
and said,
"I'll waive my professional fees. I will
treat any lawyer who sues doctors
for malpractice. I will waive my
professional fees."
Didn't get published anywhere, but I
felt good cuz I
sent it out.
Doctor said he'd lie to get insurance to
pay.
58% of doctors admitted in a survey that
was published by the American Medical
Association, 58% admitted they would lie
to get paid for procedures they didn't
even do.
They admitted they would lie to get paid
for procedures that they did do that the
patient didn't need. Now, doctors are
the only people who don't have to go to
a a bank when they need money. At the
end of the month, if they need $10,000
cuz they went to Vegas and they lost
$10,000, they can't pay their mortgage,
you're the last patient of the month,
you're going to get everything known to
medical science.
They just send in that bill to Medicare,
and they get 10,000 bucks in their
account the next day, and they pay their
bills, and everybody's happy.
According to the Health Insurance
Association of America, 75% of insurance
fraud is committed by providers, which
is a code word for doctors.
75% of all health insurance fraud is
committed by medical doctors.
You know how many medical doctors go to
jail for that each year? Zero. They're
dealt with by another standard. If you
and I were to somehow try to defraud an
insurance company, they would hire
detectives and they would hunt you down
forever and get you in jail. Medical
doctors do it with impunity. Health
insurance companies write it off as a
cost of doing business. And guess who
picks up the difference? Look in the
mirror sometime. You're the one picking
up the difference.
So, we should be striking them.
We have a history in America of doing
that kind of stuff.
We have a history of rebellion.
I don't
suggest you pick up rifles and go shoot
doctors.
Although sometimes I feel like it, but
what I'm suggesting is this. Let's do
what we've done in other industries. You
know, 60 years ago when the automobile
industry began to crank down on people,
look, you're driving a Ford car, you got
to come to a Ford dealer, we're the only
go-to people for Ford car.
And you go in for a $6 oil change 60
years ago and they say, "Look, uh
you have you had this 25,000 miles. Why
don't you let us do this check on it and
we'll do whatever's necessary." And
you've been driving and you think,
"There's nothing wrong with it. Sure, go
ahead, do the check." You come back with
a $300 bill. You say, "Why? This was
supposed to be six bucks." "Well, you
told us to check it out. You gave us
permission to do that. It's 300 bucks
cuz we rebuilt the transmission, we did
the carburetor, uh all new brake shoes,
blah blah blah, 300 bucks." And they
wouldn't give you the key until you paid
your 300 bucks. But you didn't go back
cuz you demanded, you know,
some um
redress uh from the uh manager and he
said, "Well, no, we did the work, you
got to give me the money before we give
you the keys."
And so people started going to junkyards
and garage sales and and flea markets.
They'd read books on how to maintain
their own cars and change their own oil
and do all that kind of stuff. They
stopped even thinking about going to the
dealerships. And when the junkyards and
the flea markets and the garage sales
couldn't support the demand for parts
and tools anymore, a whole industry
developed.
Now we have NAPA Auto Parts and Pep Boys
and AutoZone.
We have all these uh Jiffy Lube's all
over the place.
They only sprang up because people
wanted to do things themselves and they
were tired of being ripped off by the
dealerships.
Same thing happened in the construction
industry. Same thing happened in the
remodeling industry and in the
landscaping industry when they got
a little oppressive to the customers,
people started going to garage sales and
they went to flea markets and they'd go
to junkyards to find parts. I mean
plumbers were charging $200 to change a
float in a toilet for little old people
and the the the worst nightmares of
course the the one that people hated
were roofs. Somehow roofing companies
would sign a contract for a $6,000 roof
and if you didn't read the fine print
with revolving interest. If you didn't
pay it off in years it was $100,000,
right? People started going to garage
sales and and junkyards and flea markets
getting materials and tools to maintain
and repair their own home. Some of you
are old enough to remember back in the
60s everybody had a tool shop in their
own garage. I mean I had them uh back
then we had a table saw and a band saw
and you had all the drills. That's when
this home thing started back in the 60s
and 70s
and when the garage sales and the flea
markets and the junkyards couldn't
supply the demand for tools and
materials anymore a whole industry
developed to supply the demand. Now we
have Home Depot
and Lowe's and Menards.
You want to find out where everybody's
at this afternoon? Go out to the parking
lot at Home Depot.
Tomorrow at 2:00 after church go there.
Parking lot you can't find a parking
space in Home Depot and Lowe's and
Menards cuz people are out there doing
it themselves. And so there's clues here
on how to deal with an oppressive failed
corrupt industry. Stop using them. But
you just can't jump from the frying pan
into the fire. You have to educate
yourself. We have all these books. Let's
play doctor. Let's play herbal doctor.
Read First Aid and Cure's Dead Doctors
Don't Lie.
I mean we're talking about 50 60 dollars
worth of books
teach you how to deal with over 900
different diseases
using herbs and vitamins and minerals
and amino acids and fatty acids. We're
talking about stuff that works.
I already had three people today that
walked in the door just met them. I met
lots of people but these three people
came up and tell me
how how the products were working for
them. They were just so surprised and
happy how well they're doing on on just
taking vitamins and minerals.
They've been going to doctors for years
and couldn't solve their problems.
Before I came here, people calling me
from Atlanta, Georgia and from Portland,
Oregon dealing with problems cuz they're
they've given up on their doctors. And
so right now we have baby boomers coming
along.
There's 80 million baby boomers in the
United States alone, 80 million.
Who are sick and tired of being sick and
tired. They're They're sick of being
ripped off by the medical system.
They're trying They're getting the gu-
You know, they want the government to
solve the problem.
Well, the medical industry generates
taxes from $1.6 trillion a year.
The military industrial complex, which
the hippies were so worried about during
the '60s and '70s, only generates 400
billion.
1/4 of what the medical system. Who has
the most power? Military industrial
complex or the medical system? Clinton
tried in his first term in the first
year of his first term to deal with the
medical situation and they chewed him
up. The office of the president with all
the power and prestige and all the
departments and money available to the
president to solve a problem, it only
got worse. They just snubbed their nose
at him.
Not because they're Republicans, but
because they weren't going to let the
president of the United States interfere
with their their cash flow. And so we
have to do this cuz nobody else is going
to do it. First thing I want to talk
about is exercise. Would you believe it
or not? How many of you have heard that
exercise is good for you?
If you don't raise your hand, you're a
liar, a communist,
or you're asleep already cuz I know that
you all heard that, right? Well, this is
me when I was 18 years old. Look
familiar? Didn't have a gram of fat on
me.
I was mean as a burnt bear and I I I was
tough. I was like a rock and I could do
anything. I knew it cuz I knew it. And I
could In addition to farm work, I'd
spend a lot of time during school when
everybody else was eating lunch, I was
running up and down the stadium stairs.
I was weightlifting. I was punching the
bag. I was doing everything I could to
get tough and and so I could play sports
and I did. And then I read an article
that said there'd never been a
professional athlete ever lived to be
100, so I stopped exercising.
Cuz if exercise is good for you, there
should be a significant percentage of
professional athletes living to be 100
cuz they get paid to do it and they're
not likely to slough off. And this is a
little chart out of God Bless America.
It talks about some of the more famous
athletes that died of nutritional
deficiency diseases. Uh the oldest one
was Red Grange, died at 88. Now, you
know, Red Grange died a long time ago,
right? And then, let's see, Jesse Owens
died at 66. Jim Thorpe died at 65. Babe
Ruth died at 53. Lou Gehrig died at 38.
Wilma Rudolph, four gold medals in
track, died at 54. Babe Zaharias, one of
the greatest female athletes ever, died
at 43. Jim Fix, who invented the fitness
concept in America, died at 52. Hank
Gathers, a great basketball player, died
at 23. Wilt Chamberlain died at 63.
Reggie Lewis died at 27. Walter Payton
died at 45. Sergei Grinkov, one of the
icons of of figure skating, died at age
28. Flo Jo, uh died at 35. I don't
believe a seizure killed her. I think
something else killed her. Don Drysdale
died of a heart attack, great baseball
player, 56. Korey Stringer, football
player, died of heatstroke at age 27.
And according to
the Center for Disease Control of
Atlanta, Georgia, each year in America,
somewhere between 75,000 and 100,000
Americans under the age of 30 drop dead
while they're exercising.
Car accidents only claim 57,000.
Of those 57,000, 17,000 are killed by
drunk drivers. Look at all the hoo-ha we
have about accidents in cars. And
doctors are instructing people to
exercise. You know, it kills more people
in car accidents.
It doesn't start out you're healthy and
you die.
How many of you are boxing fans? Anybody
here a boxing fan? Okay, a few. REMEMBER
ROBERTO DURAN? NO MAS. NO MAS.
And this is about 10 years ago, I think.
Somewhere around there, 10, 12 years
ago. Not a championship, but 100 fights,
many championship fights.
Um he was in a championship 12-round
fight with Sugar Ray Leonard. I think it
was in the second round, third round,
something real early.
He just got up and said,
"I don't want to do this anymore." They
spent millions and millions of dollars
in advertising. Caesars Palace in Vegas.
I mean, there were
I don't know how many hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of bets, and
he just said, "That's it. No mas. I
don't want to do this anymore."
"I I don't like boxing anymore. This is
a cruel sport. You
Elite athletes face this hazard.
All right, talked about this guy.
Fans And he barely made the cut in this
latest by two by two strokes. I mean,
they were sweating
him even getting in. He's He's going
down, folks. I just spent weekend with
these guys with Ted and Angela.
Talk about talent. These guys had all
the talent in the world when it came to
basketball and they still lost. They got
beat by the punk team.
You think they lost cuz they didn't have
talent? You think they lost cuz they
didn't want to win?
You think they lost cuz they didn't
practice?
If you look historically at this
situation, it happens a lot where they
draft some big stars and then it didn't
work. You know, here's a whole bunch of
teams that hire these big stars at the
beginning of the season and try and make
something happen and it didn't happen.
That's a little picture of Theo Ratliff
from his own website. Theo Ratliff is a
very interesting guy. In um 2000 2001,
he missed 79 games. His career was over.
He had the best orthopedic surgeons tell
him his career was over.
His right shooting wrist turned into
dust. There was nothing bigger than a BB
in there. I mean, none of his bones were
any shape. They couldn't even put wires
or nothing in there.
He had the cartilage come loose in his
hip. They had to go and do a hip
surgery. His other hip was just as bad.
Bone-to-bone arthritis in both knees. He
was only 28 years old. His career was
over. He happened to hear some of our
distributors talking to another player
in the locker room. He says, "Hey, you
think that stuff will help me?"
In 3 months' time, all his pain went
away and his range of motion came back.
3 more months, he felt so good he tried
back out for the team and he got his old
position back.
This guy who 6 months earlier was told
that his career was over. He had all
these terrible degenerate problems. His
career was over.
Well, the last 2 years, he's been the
shot-blocking champion, the super super
defensive star in the NBA.
And that's impossible.
All his orthopedic surgeons said so.
But we put him back together just using
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
and rare earths, and amino acids, and
fatty acids. So, I'm going through a
progression here. You're going through
the emotional failures, physical
failures.
Remember I told you Jim Fix was the guy
who started during the 1970s. He started
the whole fitness thing. Up until Jim
Fix in the 1970s, nobody but people who
played team sports worked out. The
average housewife didn't go in for
aerobics and yoga. The average, you
know, Joe Carpenter, you know, the
average working man
didn't work out. Came home and drank a
beer and passed gas and watched TV.
That was his life. His great excitement
was if he, you know, won a case of beer
at bingo. Jim Fix came along and said,
"Hey, if you run 10 mi a week, we'll
keep your arteries clean, and and you
don't have to die until you're 100." And
he personally, consciously, in all his
writings, stayed away from vitamins and
minerals cuz when he lived to be 100, he
did not want anybody to say, "Well, how
do you know, Jim, it wasn't the vitamins
and minerals?"
He wouldn't even eat enriched bread. And
he died at 52 of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack, a simple deficiency of the trace
mineral selenium. Well, this fellow
here, Brian Maxwell, was one of his
protégés.
He believed in Jim Fix like you you just
have no idea how much he thought of Jim
Fix.
He thought he was like another father to
him. He invented the PowerBar. There was
no such thing as a granola bar until
Brian Maxwell. He invented them in 1983.
Actually, it was his girlfriend who was
a nutritionist cuz they kept hitting the
wall in their marathons. They At about
mile 18, they'd hit this wall and have
to walk. No matter how well they were
trained, they just couldn't go anymore.
And he was the one who invented the carb
up
thing. Like, eat spaghetti before the
big race.
Like, that's this guy that came up with
that. He just died in March of a heart
attack, cardiomyopathy heart attack, at
age 51. He'd won 14 world-level
marathons in the Olympics, World Games,
international marathon. 14 of them. He
placed in the top five in 100 of them in
his lifetime. And he died at age 51
of a cardiomyopathy heart attack, a
simple deficiency of selenium. And so,
when he died, we got on the computer,
and we looked up
the analysis of power bars. It's just
nothing but grains and some honey and
sugar and stuff like that. It's an
energy bar. It's a power bar, energy
bar.
No selenium.
Okay, one more clue. Well, two more
clues.
This is a small study, only 158 sudden
deaths of young athletes This is from 12
to 40. And of the 158 sudden deaths, 48
of them were in basketball.
Only one was in boxing.
Isn't boxing a more dangerous sport than
basketball? Not according to this.
48 of 158 to die in this little study
were basketball players. How many of you
have been to a professional basketball
game?
Well, if you've never been to a
professional basketball game, or even a
college basketball game,
they have a team of people with towels.
And during the free throws and the time
outs, what do they do? They're out there
wiping the sweat off the floor so the
players don't slip when they get under
the basket and all that traffic is going
on the basket.
They're out there wiping that sweat out
from underneath the basket. There's
another little clue.
June 9th,
this gal here, uh Rolanda Pierce, 19
years old, 6'5, Florida State
University. She was going to be the big
savior
of women's professional basketball when
she graduated from college. I mean, she
was the big up-and-comer. She died of a
ruptured aneurysm at age 19.
Ruptured aortic aneurysm. A copper
deficiency. I mean, we eliminated
ruptured aneurysms in turkeys in the
1950s.
She died of something that even a turkey
wouldn't die from. I guarantee you she
had the finest sports medical doctors,
she had the finest trainers
the money could pay for. But she died of
something that a turkey wouldn't die
from. Cuz I guarantee you she was just
living on Coca-Colas and curly french
fries. Doesn't seem to matter what sport
it is.
Ray Lundy from Newport Beach,
California, died at 14 of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack
training for water polo.
This gal here, Helen Moros,
the top runner, smoke-free,
top marathon runner in Australia, died
at 35 of cardiomyopathy a attack. Does
she look healthy to you?
She looks like an escapee from a death
camp in Germany to me. I mean, look at
her Look at her arms. I mean, she does
not look like a healthy person. We
talked about Sergei Grinkov.
Age 28, died of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack. The darlings of the pairs figure
skating world. One more, maybe two more,
then I'll tell you why.
Reggie Lewis. At 27, he collapsed with a
cardiomyopathy heart attack. They
diagnosed it correctly, cardiomyopathy
heart attack. A simple uh deficiency of
the trace mineral selenium.
They got 12 cardiologists from around
the world, the top 12 cardiologists from
around the world, and they paid them a
million dollars each to refer This is
the Celtics. They paid them a million
dollars each to refer their patients out
to other doctors so they could devote
their full time to saving Reggie.
He's their top financial player,
and they wanted to save him, get him
back in the game. And they were arguing
amongst themselves who was going to do
the transplant, who was going to give
him a pacemaker, could he play with a
transplanted heart, could he play with a
pacemaker if they put it in the right
position, and all that kind of stuff.
And while they were arguing about this,
he dies. Three years later, he dies.
Second cardiomyopathy heart attack.
Well, if you wait long enough, justice
has a way of coming around, right? God
works in mysterious ways.
The chief, the captain of the dream team
of cardiology, the medical doctor who
ran the Boston Marathon all the time. He
wasn't a a couch potato. He was the
designated sports medical doctor for the
people who ran the Boston Marathon. He
taught cardiology at Harvard Medical
School in Boston. One Dr. W. Thomas
Nessa. A year and a half after Reggie
died, at age 48, dies of the same thing.
Dr. W. Thomas Nessa, a member of the
dream team of cardiologists who treated
the late I mean, I'd have been
embarrassed if I was part of his family
to put that in there. I mean, this guy
is malignant dumb. Died Saturday in his
home in you know,
prophetically, he lived in a town called
Dedham. At age 48. Now, if your
cardiologist dies of a heart attack at
age 48, how much belief should you have
in him? But people say, "Oh, isn't it
terrible Dr. Nessa died of a heart
attack?" And they'll keep following his
advice.
Now, if he was my cardiologist and died
at age 48 of a heart attack, he said no
salt, I'd be taking the top off the salt
shaker and guzzling salt. He said no
eggs, I'd eat 25 a day. He said exercise
was good for it, I'd lay there and I
wouldn't even blink. I would not do
anything to resemble exercise, cuz I
wouldn't want to get what he got. If
that's what you get for following what
he was saying, I wouldn't want to do it.
Well, the hint is of course athletes
sweat more in 5 years than couch
potatoes do in 75 years. You know
there's more librarians living to be
100, there's never been a professional
athlete ever lived to be 100.
It's pretty scary. Now, when I showed
that to these guys in
in the Vegas, I mean they really got
concerned. Also,
carbonated drinks
will increase your risk of osteoporosis
and fractures by 500%. I stood up there
on the stage and I told them, if I was a
trainer, if I was a owner, I would not
even let my players in the same room
with carbonated drinks.
Cuz they're big problems. Reason why
they
fall out, joint problems, bone problems,
ligament problems, cartilage problems.
They're all sitting there guzzling all
those carbonated drinks.
Doctors lack proof that too much salt is
unhealthful. This came out almost
exactly
7 years ago. This was presented the
annual meeting of the American Heart
Association in Portland, Oregon. After
years of telling healthy people that too
much salt isn't good for them,
researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up that claim. Now,
what does a good farmer or rancher put
out for his livestock?
Salt block or salt lick, right? There's
nobody out in the pasture telling a cow
she's limited to one lick a day, is
there?
I refuse to believe my human patients
were dumber than a cow.
I look, go ahead and salt your food to
taste, salt your body, don't worry about
it.
Well, how do I know if I'm getting too
much? Well, it won't taste good. That's
high-tech answer, right?
If it tastes too salty, don't eat it. If
it tastes good, eat it. That's very
simple.
Works like a charm. Salt has nothing to
do with high blood pressure. Genetics
has nothing to do with high blood
pressure. None. Nothing.
That's the first thing they say.
Do you have anybody in your family with
high blood pressure? Yes. Okay, you're
going to get blood pressure medicated.
Well, I don't have high blood, but it's
in your family.
Genetics has nothing to do with it. Salt
has nothing to do with it. In fact, the
government spent $30 million on what
they called the sodium task force and
this came out in 1997. On the bottom
line it said, "The study found that
people who limited their salt intake to
1,000 mg or 1 g a day which which was
what medical doctors
recommend to you,
the people who followed the doctor's
instructions had six times more heart
attacks, 600% more heart attacks than
those who defied their doctors and ate
double that amount of salt."
It's a government study. They're trying
to prove that salt was bad. You had to
get rid of salt. They couldn't do it.
It was not true. Salt is an essential
nutrient. You get too much, you won't
like it.
So, what causes high blood pressure?
High blood pressure is caused by a
simple deficiency of a single nutrient.
Now, we've eliminated that deficiency in
animals.
Pigs and horses and cows and canaries
and parakeets and dogs and cats and
salamanders and crickets can all get
high blood pressure. But, they don't get
high blood pressure not because they
don't have the genetics to get it. They
don't get high blood pressure because
remember I said we got these little
pellets?
Cuz they don't have insurance to pay for
calcium channel blockers and beta
blockers for dogs. And so, we just put
that little mineral and all its
cofactors in those pellets called
calcium.
You can drink 50 gallons of milk a day
and you can't get enough calcium to
lower your blood pressure. You can eat
25 lb of cheese a day. You can't get
enough calcium to lower your blood
pressure. The only thing that'll happen
is you'll be so constipated you'll need
a jackhammer to have a bowel movement.
If you didn't have hemorrhoids, you're
going to get them. And so, as part of
our basic program, the basic program
with all the known essential nutrients
to support maintenance and repair, it's
a mindless thing. You don't have to
Let's see, I need two of these and I got
my ratios and oh, 40 bottles of this and
We've done it all for you. 100 billion
dollars worth of research. We put it in
those bottles. Obesity quickly. 62% of
Americans overweight, 40% are obese.
And you know, there's all these diets.
There's the Atkins diet. There's the
South Beach diet. There's the Zone diet.
And all they do is parse words on
percentages of low glycemic carbs and
fat and you know, well, I I like 20%.
No, no, I like 22%. It's going off the
stick. It's nothing is touching it.
Well, my wife and I are finishing up a
book
cuz we know the cause of obesity. I
mean, veterinarians know the cause of
this because when you put an animal into
the feed lot, when you put a steer in
the feed lot, what is your goal? Make
them fat. Prime beef is fat. We know how
to do it. We know the technology to do
it. And when you reverse engineer it,
you can make lean beef.
Oh, I mean, that's mysterious. We've
been doing this forever. So, I got tired
of just telling everybody
goes in one ear and out the other. Some
people doesn't take the ferret fat pack.
Lose a few pounds, right? But, there's a
lot of technology in that ferret fat
package. It's not another diet cuz it's
been engineered to work based on what
they taught me in 4 years in
agricultural school, in 4 years in
veterinary school, and 45 years of
experience. When that book comes out,
it's going to be a shocker to everybody
because it's going to be so far
different than anybody else is doing
because none of them have even come
close to the cause of the problem.
They're just trying to deal with the
symptom, fat.
The reason why people get fat again is
because they haven't dealt with the
basic systemic problem. Obesity on Track
is number one preventable killer. Ooh,
that's important. Well, here is the
secret of obesity. If you recognize
what's going on in that picture as a
work wagon
of a little Amish farm
in Lancaster County, Pennsylvania,
Intercourse, Pennsylvania. That's off a
little Amish farm. And I walked onto the
farm and said, "What do you feed your
horses?" "Oh, we just give them ground
corn and or they can get out of the
pasture and a little bit of hay."
Well, you got a problem. He said, "Yeah,
they get lame all the time." I want you
to look at that wagon. You see anything
wrong with that wagon? Yeah, I heard him
say chewed up. That's right. Those
horses have chewed that plank out of
that wagon. That's where the farmer jump
off that wagon all the time with a
sweaty hand, impregnate that wood with
salt. Now, why were those horses chewing
on that salty wood? Cuz they're mineraly
deficient. It's called pica. How many of
you heard the term pica?
Pregnant women do that all the time.
They eat dirt.
It's so common in the south part of the
United States, they actually sell clay
in little bags. You can get white clay,
blue clay, red clay, yellow clay. They
sell it in the grocery stores cuz people
women pregnant women have cravings.
How many of you heard of pregnant women
getting cravings?
Okay, any woman who's ever been pregnant
has a craving, right? That's because the
baby is stealing minerals from the
mother and she's not taking them in fast
enough to replace what the baby's
stealing from her. We've been taught
that socially unacceptable to eat dirt
and chew on the furniture, so we eat
snacks. If you're that hungry and you're
eating dirt or, you know, you're eating
dirt as a kid. Bam, don't do that.
You'll embarrass me. If you're that
hungry, go in there and eat a Moon Pie
and a RC.
Get them potato chips.
This is not a secret.
The snack food industry knows about all
this stuff. They engineer their
The motto of Lay's potato chips is what?
It's written right on the bag. You can't
just eat one.
Cuz they engineer when you open that
bag, you're going to eat the entire bag
and you're going to look for a second
bag. It's engineered for that. It's not
a mystery.
And so
if every kid
who had these cravings, you all know
them during especially during the
holiday. You've just eaten a
seven-course dinner and you open up that
refrigerator and you're standing there
staring in there. What are you doing,
Frank? I gave you a seven-course dinner
for Christmas and you're just staring at
the fridge. I don't know, I just need
something. I don't know what it is. I'm
just looking for something. Because
calories don't solve the problems of a
mineral deficiency.
When you take minerals, you're not
really hungry anymore.
And so it's really easy to cut back on
the food because you're not hungry
anymore.
I'll just show you two gals. This gal's
from um Nashville, Tennessee, Ann
Hausenbauer. Lost 90 lb in 11 months.
Good-looking lady. And did great. And I
like this little gal. Terry Mooney from
Fenton, Michigan.
Lost 60 lb in 8-month period. She went
from this, kind of like a I'd say a farm
wife kind of look, to this. Same girl.
She's only 25 years old, but she looked
like she was 40 years old farm wife.
Look at her now.
And so we have thousands of people, both
men and women, who've lost a lot of
weight.
Diabetes is an epidemic. Diabetes is an
epidemic. It kind of goes along with
this obesity thing. A million new cases
a year in the United States alone makes
up 12% of the American population, 32
million diabetics. Of them, 95% are 31
million are adult onset type 2
diabetics. And adult onset type 2
diabetics
make tons of insulin. They make as much
as 10 times more insulin than
non-diabetics.
It's not an insulin problem. They make
more insulin. That's why they can take
pills or maybe even with diet and
exercise, they can kind of control their
diabetes cuz they make plenty of
insulin.
We learned in 1957, when it was actually
printed, published in medical journals
in 1957,
that we could prevent and cure. Those
are two profound words. We could prevent
and cure adult onset type 2 diabetes in
laboratory animals, pet animals, and
farm animals in 1957 with two trace
minerals and their cofactors.
The medical doctors said, "Well, there's
no evidence to support a claim that you
can prevent and cure diabetes in human
beings."
And so it laid dormant in human medicine
for
20 years until 1977.
And then a a guy who couldn't speak
English very well, a medical doctor who
couldn't speak English, who they put in
charge of a coma center cuz he didn't
have to talk to the patients, right?
They're all in comas.
They put him in charge of a coma center,
so all he had to do was read records.
And he noticed that
the people who survived 3 months in this
coma center
always got adult onset type 2 diabetes.
100% of them, after 3 months, 100%
regardless of their race, their age,
their gender, nothing mattered. If they
lived 3 months in that coma center, they
got adult onset type 2 diabetes. They
were waiting. They started testing them
at about 2 and 1/2 months.
Sure enough, they'd always get diabetes
by 3 months. They'd give them insulin,
they'd control them.
And he made the mental leap that there
had to be something missing in the
feeding tube that they were giving them
because it didn't matter their age,
their race, their gender, didn't matter
anything. If they lived there 3 months
in a coma, they got adult onset type 2.
And so he made the correct
thought that they were missing
something. So he So he starts reading.
And sure enough he goes back 20 years
and he finds his research in animals. He
says, "Well, that seems simple. You
couldn't give them these alfalfa pellets
with all these minerals in them because
they're in a coma." And so he took that
formula and made it into an IV which he
added to their basic feeding tube and in
72 hours he cured them all of their
adult onset type 2 diabetes. Published
in every medical journal in the world.
This gets published every two or three
years because people getting their PhD
in endocrinology and they're studying
diabetes they run into that and they
say, "Well, that can't be." So they try
to redo it and sure enough it repeats
and so they publish it again. And so
this is not a mystery. Every medical
doctor knows this. They're not going to
do that because they'll get 30 bucks for
an extended visit. Well, according to
the GAO, the General Accounting Office,
which is the budget watchdog for the US
Congress,
the average income that a doctor gets
off of a type 2 diabetic who lives 25 to
40 years after diagnosis is $750,000.
There's no law requiring him to cure
people when there's cures available. So
which way is he going to go? 30 bucks or
$750,000? Now, you don't need to be a
rocket scientist to figure that one out.
I just talked to the um president of the
NBA Players Association. His wife
has
diabetes. I just asked her one question.
Do you drink soft drinks? She said, "Oh
yeah, I'm a Coca-Cola-holic. I have to
have 20 or 30 a day." Well,
look at this. This is a study on 91,000
women over 8 years.
91,000 nurses over 8 years.
Women in the study who drank at least
one sugar sweetened soda
were 85% more likely to develop type 2
diabetes than ones who just drank water
or even diet Coke.
85% increase. You're going to get it.
If you drink one Coca-Cola a day, it's
just a matter of time. If you drink two,
it's going to be faster. If you drink
three, it's faster.
But if you just drink one a day, you
have an 85% chance of getting diabetes.
And you know,
when you talk to people about it, "Oh
no, my doctor says genetic." Whatever
turns your crank.
Cut way back on the carbohydrates. Eat
six small meals a day with animal
protein in them.
Watch what happens. Weight goes down.
Blood sugar goes down. you live a normal
life. Well, I have to ask my doctor
permission.
Okay, last one is arthritis and
osteoporosis. According to the Center
for Disease Control, 85% of Americans
after the age of 50 or by the age of 50
already have osteoporosis or arthritis
of one type or another, to one degree or
another. There's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or fix it.
Aspirin,
Celebrex, Vioxx, Tylenol, I
ibuprofen, Advil, Aleve, methotrexate,
gold shots, prednisone, cortisone, none
of them fix it. They all have terrible
side effects, many of which are
life-threatening.
And cure arthritis and osteoporosis in
animals over 300 years ago in Europe and
over 1,000 years ago in Asia. So, why
don't doctors use that? Well, there's no
money in it.
There's Remember we already said there's
no money in the cure?
If Doc Smith were to cure all his
patients of arthritis and osteoporosis
today,
and the word got out he was curing
people, the the line would go around the
earth three times.
And he'd have one heck of a good month.
But, what do you do for the rest of his
life? He'd be broke because
there's no money in the cure. The money
is in milking the insurance program. If
you follow your doctor when it comes to
arthritis and osteoporosis and other
degenerative diseases, this is what
you're going to look like by the time
you're 75, 80 years old.
Woohoo!
And then I'd look forward to that. Man,
oh man, diabetes, back surgery,
hip replacements, knee replacements,
bone spurs, high blood pressure,
Alzheimer's disease,
triple bypass.
I'll bet you he was a very Whatever you
say, doctor.
Now, this problem starts
when you're young. This problem starts
when you're
weaned off of milk.
I see so many kids today, thousands of
them a month, thousands a month.
Oh, he has Charlie horse. He's three
years old and he has leg cramps, and
doctor says it's growing pains. I know
it's something different.
Well, you give him any supplements? No.
Are you giving him apple Oh, he Oh, he
loves apple juice and orange juice. He
and grape juice. I mean, he just lives
for orange juice and grape juice and
apple juice.
Well, how much calcium and magnesium and
boron and strontium and
silica are in there? How much sulfur is
in apple juice and grape juice? Uh none.
This is out of Australia, but this is
absolutely true. I just like this cuz of
the little red this island of Tasmania.
3/4 of young Australians and Americans
age 12 to 15 are not getting enough
calcium. 75% cuz they're all living on
bottled water. They're all living on
apple juice and grape juice and and
worse yet Oh, yeah, Sunny D, Sunny
Delight.
Yeah. It's only 2% juice. It says right
on the label, 2% juice. The rest of it
sugar water. But every kid loves it cuz
they got great advertising on TV.
I have to have my Sunny Delight. Crack.
This is the one that really shook up the
players.
Arthroscopic knee surgery for arthritis
is worthless. Yet the 5,000 doctors in
America who specialize in arthroscopic
knee surgery for degenerative joint
disease, in 2001 their income from that
one procedure is 1.5 billion dollars.
Why would they give it up? There's no
law requiring to give it up just cuz
it's useless.
Last slide, this is the one you've been
waiting for. Osteoporosis strikes both
sexes equally. Since 1958, doctors
wanted you to believe that osteoporosis
was primarily a postmenopausal woman's
problem. Would you believe it or not?
How many of you have heard that? If you
don't raise your hand, you're a liar.
You're a commie, you're asleep cuz I
know you've all heard it. But
osteoporosis strikes men equally with
women. How come you men aren't being
shuttled through getting your bone
density test like women? Well, because
doctors make too much money on HRT
kickbacks.
And if they were to let women know that
men get it equally with with women, how
could you justify giving estrogen which
causes increase in cancer, Alzheimer's
disease, and cardiovascular disease?
You couldn't justify it cuz I mean, how
many red-blooded American men are going
to walk into their OB/GYN and say,
"Okay, doc, I got osteoporosis in my
family. I want you to shoot me up with
that uh I know that estrogen stuff."
That's not going to happen, is it? And
so, that's why there is no carbonated
drinks,
and give up fried foods and margarines,
and cooking oils, and meat cooked well
done, and burnt animal fats. Just doing
those things, you'll add 30, 40, 50
healthful years to your life.
Uh I have to ask my doctor.
Information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration and are not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
disease.